hello friends I am back on your internet
screen and here today to talk about
color you know that thing that makes the
work interesting and vibrant that's what
we're gonna talk about a color is my
favorite part of the creative process
but it can be really intimidating do it
right and it'll make everything look
beautiful do it wrong and it'll make
your eyes bleed not literally of course
but it'll look pretty bad like really
bad now I'm sure a lot of you out there
struggle with how to use color so today
we're gonna cover some basics think of
it like the ABCs of red yellow and blue
and better yet I'm gonna give you some
handy tips to use along the way so you
can hack your color growth in five easy
steps kidding this is not that kind of
video but there are numbered tips okay
you ready let's do this this is the
color wheel it's a wheel and it's made
of well colors which which makes sense
right so every color breaks down into
three fundamental ingredients hue
saturation and value now these terms
sound all sciency and smart but they're
really easy to grasp I mean if I can
make sense of them then you're gonna be
just fine let's start with you
but not that you cute is literally the
color that you are looking at it's like
the main ingredient in a colors recipe
red green violet all hues the second
attribute of a color is saturation and
saturation is the intensity of a hue
think of it like the level of spiciness
in a flavor take blue for example add
some saturation to it and the intensity
really increases add too much saturation
and it goes all Internet 1.0 conversely
if we dial back that saturation we lose
the intensity and our hyperlink blue
becomes very dull almost grey now the
last slice of this color pie is value
and value is basically the brightness of
a color now there are two terms for
value you'll hear tint and shade the
tint is a brighter version of a hue
meaning it's mixed with white while a
shade is a darker version it's mixed
with black you still with me
cool
now you might be thinking but Greg how
do I use colors together great question
let's take a look at this example yikes
okay wow that just that's bad the color
is so bad I wish I could unsee this so
let's get rid of that there we go now
this works and it's so much easier on
the eyes but why is that well let's
break it down so here are the top three
reasons why your color is probably suck
number one you're using too many colors
remember that color wheel I know it's
pretty but unless you're making
magnificent rainbows then you probably
don't need to use that many colors you
should probably stick with a few up most
if we're going back to the cooking
analogy you don't need to use every
spice in the rack number two too much
saturation another case of a little goes
a long way when every color in a design
is set to the highest possible intensity
it kind of makes you go think of your
color scheme like music and I know I'm
changing analogies on you here but you
don't want the volume of all the
instruments to be set to 11 the whole
time I like to start around here in the
color spectrum and then adjust the taste
as I go number three not enough contrast
life is all about contrast
you can't have happy moments without sad
ones and there is no light without dark
now when you're pairing colors together
make sure you have enough contrast
between them so here's a quick trick you
can use to figure out how much contrast
you have let's say you have three colors
to work with and you want to figure out
if there's enough contrast between them
easy make the image black-and-white by
removing hue from the equation you can
easily see their value and then make
adjustments now let's put that knowledge
to use bring up those horrible colors
again please yep still the worst let's
do something about that now right away I
know we have way too many colors going
on but I'm going to start by looking at
the contrast let's add a black and white
filter so you can see most of the colors
are really really similar in value and
that's probably the reason why it's so
hard to look at and why we don't really
know where to focus you know what here
let's sample this color too I just want
to see what's what's going on because I
have a suspicion that yeah okay
things like crazy saturated it's like
almost to the very edge it's like neon
we got some work to do so let's fix this
thing Wow okay what a difference this
makes here now look at this your eyes
being led around the image so you have
dark values you have really light values
you have kind of Gray's in the middle
this is so much better so much but ah so
much better than that Wow okay I think
all we need now are some finishing
touches so here I'm gonna go in and
select these little guys and just kind
of boost the saturation a little bit
since it's so small and it's kind of
nice to have a little a little bit of a
flourish there and then I'll bring these
up just just a touch not much you know
like this is where it's okay to bump
that saturation those little little kind
of things I had a color balance for this
what I'll do is just some kind of global
color correction so I'm gonna go in the
shadows and I'm gonna pull out some of
the reds so the so the kind of darker
parts cool down a little bit
alright and then we'll add some blue
alright so you see it's starting to cool
down a little okay and then the contrast
that will go to the let's go to the
highlights and I'll like add some maybe
some yellow back and some some warmth
back in there
and let's see how that looks before
after it's a it's a very subtle thing
but it kind of helps like bring
everything together and make it a bit
more uniform yeah I'm happy with that I
think it looks great and by contrast eek
yeah we're in good shape well buddies
we've reached the end of our internet
time together sad I know now before I go
into the Edit and cringe at the sound of
my own voice I want to leave you with
something do me a favor hop down into
the description of this video
and you'll find a bunch of links to cool
colored resources that you can use
they're both fun and super helpful
that's about it alright see you next
time oh and uh consider subscribing if
you like this video look for a big red
button I think it says subscribe or
something on it okay bye E